so what map are we looking at tonight
who's going to win
trump for the flag burners who's going
to win my math
and you know me i don't i don't consult
the horoscope i don't
uh have a cookie shop i but
i did make my prediction so my math is
all
it's going to be all red uh and plus
greenland
so greenland also red so a lot of people
talking about 538 538 electoral votes
that's happening
i'm going to say 623 because i'm going
to give greenland to 85 electoral votes
why
i don't know why not it's a big big
landmass i don't know how many people
are there but that's fine seems big
that's what i want and i'm i'm only half
joking i'm only
i don't i don't think the whole entire
country is going to vote for trump
but i i don't know what's going to
happen
if if i wake up tomorrow well i guess
i'll still be on set tonight
if i find out tonight that joe biden won
narrowly
wouldn't be surprised if trump won
narrowly wouldn't be surprised if i find
out that
biden won in a big way you know he got a
huge number of electoral votes i guess i
wouldn't be that surprised
it would that would surprise me a little
bit more and if i found out trump won
40 states or some some crazy you know
some insane number like that
i also wouldn't be that surprised i
don't know
the models are only as good as the data
you put in and we're in such a bizarre
year
with the unprecedented widespread
unsolicited male in ballots
with the coronavirus lockdowns i guess
coronavirus is not unprecedented we've
had epidemics like this and actually
much worse than this before
but the lockdowns the politicization of
the coronavirus by the left mostly
is unprecedented the degree of fraud
that you've seen i'm not talking about
fraud even at the polling places
although
attorney general shapiro should make us
a little worried about that in
pennsylvania
but i'm talking about the fraud in the
bureaucracy itself
this is the first coup d'etat in my
lifetime what happened in 2016 to the
present
is the first attempted coup in my
lifetime
there have been others in the united
states but first one since i've been
alive
so i don't know how to factor that into
my calculations
there is a strange phenomenon going on
which is these organic
trump parades you know because there
haven't been quite as many rallies i
think trump's done something like
12 rallies in the last few days i mean
he's he's just absolutely killing in the
last few days on the campaign trail
but because there haven't been as many
rallies and formal events as there have
been in years past
people are just creating their own trump
parades
i've seen them in california i've seen
them all over the place people getting
their cars through the trucks and they
have an american flag and they have a
trump flag and
maybe a gadsden flag something like that
and they go down and they go on for
miles and miles and miles
you don't see that you haven't seen that
but you don't see any biden parades
there are no but not one
time has there been a biden parade
that that shows you that something is
going on in the country i suspect
that enthusiasm difference is going to
factor into the
election results even if it doesn't low
and let's say that there isn't fraud for
a second
that still tells you something about our
politics because you've got a country
that is so starkly divided and not just
about this issue or that
issue not just about taxes not just
about certain rates of immigration
not not even about really serious issues
like abortion
but about the country itself some people
like the country
want more of it have loyalty to their
country love it
and and other people don't love it they
hate it they hate it
they want to fundamentally transform it
i'm not saying this even as
like a cheap political shot i'm saying
if you ask them they'd say yeah i hate
this country
i love what this com what they would
usually say is this no i love our
country
i hate what we were but i love what we
could be i hate what we are now but i
love
what we could be if we only live up to
the ideals that i
i invented five seconds ago not that
george washington or thomas jefferson
invented but that i invented
sure if you if you hate what a country
is now and you hate what a country was
in the past
and you enjoy what you think the country
could be in the future because you've
got a crystal ball
that means you hate your country you
like your daydreams
and you hate your country
and that is a that's a fundamental
distinction chesterton famously said
that there's a thought that stops
thought and that's the only thought that
ought to be stopped
that there are there are principles that
we have to take on faith there are
axioms that we need to begin with
in this country in any country and one
of them is you have to love your country
you have to have patriotism you have to
support it you have to not try to
destroy it you don't have to not try not
to subvert it
and and we're having a disagreement over
that question right now
so even let's say biden wins fair and
square
hope doesn't happen let's say it does
that puts us in a very
very bad position i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you